Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Twelve: customs and days of observance.
In Denmark, a number of public holidays, days of observance and special customs are celebrated through the year.
On many of these days children have the day off from school and adults have the day off from work.
Denmark is, by the way, one of the only countries in the world that does not have an actual official national day.
Fastelavn.
Fastelavn is another word for carnival.
It is a spring festival that can be traced back to the ancient Roman Empire and Egypt.
Fastelavn in Denmark was originally the entrance to the fasting period within the Christian faith.
According to old custom, children dress up and hit a barrel.
In the old days there was a live cat in the barrel, and the one who breaks the barrel is still called the cat queen or cat king.
Today there is sweets and fruit in the barrel.
Fastelavn is seven weeks before Easter.
Easter, påske.
The Christian Easter marks that Jesus was crucified, died and rose from the dead.
In Denmark Easter is often used for family parties.
From old times there is a tradition of giving each other Easter eggs.
The egg is an old fertility symbol.
Today Easter eggs are often made of chocolate.
In addition there is a tradition of eating lamb, since the lamb symbolises Easter's message that Jesus was sacrificed as an innocent lamb for people's sins.
Easter falls every year in March or April.
The first of May.
The labour movement's international day of struggle is celebrated with parades, political speeches and events all over the country.
Both the trade union movement and the parties that stem from the trade union movement, the Social Democrats, SF and the Red-Green Alliance, are behind these events.
Pentecost, pinse.
With the Christian Pentecost, people celebrate that the Holy Spirit, according to the Bible, has come to earth.
Pentecost was originally the end of seven weeks of joyful celebration after Easter.
At Pentecost some have the tradition of getting up early to see the sun "dance" and of having a Pentecost lunch, for example by bringing a picnic basket to the forest.
Pentecost falls every year in May or June, seven weeks after Easter.
Constitution Day, grundlovsdag.
The fifth of June is Constitution Day, when people meet and in speeches celebrate Denmark's democratic constitution, Danmarks Riges Grundlov.
Denmark got its first constitution in 1849.
Sankthans, Saint John's.
On the evening of the 23rd of June, Sankthans is celebrated.
The background for celebrating Sankthans eve is a mix of pagan folk tradition and Christianity.
The festival marks midsummer, and according to old custom bonfires are burned.
The name Hans is an abbreviation of Johannes, and Sankthans is in a church context a marking of John the Baptist's birthday on the 24th of June.
Christmas, julen.
At Christmas, Jesus's birth is celebrated.
Christmas Eve is the 24th of December, when families gather, eat together and give each other presents.
Most dance around the Christmas tree and sing Christmas hymns.
Many also go to church for the Christmas service.
Christmas thus has roots both in Christianity and in pagan folk tradition with a marking of the winter solstice, when the day length is shortest, and from there we move towards lighter times.
The 25th and 26th of December are called first and second Christmas Day.
Here many families gather for Christmas lunch.
New Year, nytår.
New Year's Eve, the 31st of December, is the year's last day.
Parties are typically held and fireworks are set off all over the country.
On New Year's Day, the first of January, the vast majority of workplaces and shops are closed.
Other holy days and days of observance.
The increased cultural exchange in the world has also brought a number of other customs and days of observance to Denmark.
Some of them are due to more Danes with foreign backgrounds having come.
The Muslim fasting month Ramadan is marked in Denmark.
So is the Feast of Sacrifice, Eid al-Adha, which marks the end of the annual pilgrimage to Mecca, and is one of the most important Islamic holidays.
The most important holy day in the Jewish year is Yom Kippur, the Day of Atonement, which is used for a personal spiritual cleansing, where you get the opportunity to put away any old enmity and ask for forgiveness as well as repent your sins and do penance through prayer and fasting.
Likewise some celebrate Halloween on the 31st of October as in the USA.
Children dress up as witches, ghosts or similar, and lanterns are made of hollowed-out pumpkins.
In several places in the country carnival is also celebrated after a South American model, with dressing up, samba music and parades.
The biggest carnival is held at Pentecost in Copenhagen.
These days are called mærkedage, days of observance, and helligdage, public holidays.
At fastelavn, children dress up and slå katten af tønden, hit the cat out of the barrel.
Here is your recap for Episode Twelve.
Denmark is one of the only countries without an actual official national day.
Fastelavn is carnival, seven weeks before Easter, where children dress up and hit a barrel; the one who breaks it is the cat queen or cat king.
Easter, in March or April, marks that Jesus was crucified and rose from the dead; people give Easter eggs and eat lamb.
The first of May is the labour movement's international day of struggle.
Pentecost, in May or June, is seven weeks after Easter, and celebrates the Holy Spirit.
The fifth of June is Constitution Day.
Sankthans on the 23rd of June is midsummer, with bonfires, and marks John the Baptist's birthday on the 24th.
Christmas Eve is the 24th of December, and the 25th and 26th are first and second Christmas Day.
New Year's Eve is the 31st of December.
Other days include Ramadan, Eid al-Adha, Yom Kippur, Halloween on the 31st of October, and the carnival in Copenhagen at Pentecost.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How is Sankthans traditionally celebrated in Denmark?
Option A: People gather in the evening and light a bonfire.
Option B: People hold a party and give each other presents.
Option C: People dress up and hit the cat out of the barrel.
[DA] Hvordan fejrer man traditionelt sankthans i Danmark?  A: Man samles om aftenen og tænder bål  |  B: Man holder fest og giver hinanden gaver  |  C: Man klæder sig ud og slår katten af tønden
The answer is A: People gather in the evening and light a bonfire.
It appeared in the June 2021 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Man samles om aftenen og tænder bål
That's the end of this part.
Well done.